[Music]
greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A I'm
Ricky Carter and I'll be your host well
we've got another hour packed program
with your Bible questions and you know
what we've got the answers right here in
the word of God I want to introduce you
to our panel so right here to my right I
have sister Shelley Quinn it's a joy to
be here as always amen amen glad to have
you here thank you and next to her I
have my brother Daniel moricone welcome
brother thank you so much what a
blessing it is to get into God's word
together amen amen and then to his right
we have another Daniel brother Daniel
pin welcome Daniel thank you I'm excited
to be here today amen amen well before
we get into our program you know it's
always good to start off with a word of
prayer so we can understand God's word
we want to invite the holy spirit's
presence to be with us so brother Marone
could you lead us in prayer absolutely
thank you Father in Heaven Lord we do
thank you for your Holy Spirit inspiring
the writers the authors of this your
word Lord we're inviting and thanking
you for giving us your Holy Spirit just
now as we all our viewers and ourselves
open your word together thanking you
ahead of time for what your Holy Spirit
Will Reveal to us of you and your love
for us we thank you for this in Jesus
precious name amen am amen amen thank
you Shel I've got your first question
but before I ask you that question let
me remind our viewers how they can
participate you can participate one of
three ways you can email your questions
to Bible QA at 3m. TV that's Bible QA
3m. second way is you can text us your
questions to 618 228
3975 that's 618 228
3975 and then the Third Way for those of
you who are on Instagram you can send us
your questions in that way at
3more official that's at 3more official
all right shell here's your first
question during creation God said let us
make man in our image after our likeness
who is God talking with or to that's
from OA in Arc Arkansas and that was
emailed to us OA this is a question that
is often asked I'm just going to use two
scripture references but let's let's go
back to the beginning when we're looking
at the record of Creation in Genesis 1
and then it is repeated and enlarged in
Genesis 2 God spoke everything into
existence until it came time to create
man whom he formed Out of the Dust of
the earth he got up close in person
breathed into his nostrils and Genesis
1:26 said let us make man in our image
according to our likeness so the use of
plural pronouns us and our this suggests
that there's multiple members of the
godhead and scripture from Genesis to
Revelation convinces me that there are
three persons in the godhead God the
Father Son and Holy Spirit and there's
58 at least 58 to 60 passages in the
Bible that references these three
persons of the godhead they were all
present at creation including the holy
spirit because it said the spirit of God
hovered over the face of the waters now
let's look at what Jesus said in Mark 12
29 through3 that's Mark 12
29-30
Jesus when ask what's the most important
commandment he repeats the shach this is
something found in Deuteronomy 6:4 he's
quoting from Deuteronomy 6:4 Jesus said
here o Israel the Lord Our God the Lord
is one and you shall love the Lord your
God with all of your heart with with all
of your soul with all of your mind and
with all of your strength this is the
first commandment in Deuteronomy 6:4
that Jesus is quoting the word for one
is in the Hebrew
is and it can indicate a compound Unity
so let's look at this how can three
equal one people will tell me all the
time if you've got father son and spirit
that's 1 + 1+ one that's
three but that's the wrong mathematical
formula we need to look at God who is
the same all three persons are the same
in nature and and the character their
purpose their plans it is one times one
times one which equals one that's one to
the third power are one cubed and so God
the father son and spirit were present
at creation they created Adam and Eve in
God's the image of the godhead giving
them free will and creative power amen
amen thank you sister all right brother
Marone here's your first question all
right could you please explain 1
Corinthians Ians 11:
14-6 and that was emailed to us all
right thank you for that question let me
go ahead and read that question I mean
that scripture then we'll know what
we're talking about here does not even
nature itself teach you that if a man
have long hair it is a shame unto him
but if a woman have long hair it is a
glory to her for her hair is given for a
covering but if any man seem to be
contentious we have no such custom
neither the Churches of God so this is
actually dealing with communal worship
there in Corinth and the head coverings
for a woman that's what this chapter 11
is really talking about in the Greco
Roman
culture uh there is in Corinth if a
woman didn't have her head covered in
public it was considered
immodest this letter to the Corinthian
Church was sent to deal with the
problems that Paul had heard were
happening in the church at Corinth and
Paul had said in chapter 10: 23 that all
things are lawful for me but all things
are not expedient all things are lawful
but they're not they don't edify so he's
saying just because it's okay for him to
do something doesn't mean that he should
do it he needed to consider the effect
it would have on others and their
concept of Christians there wasn't
anything intrinsically wrong with a
woman not having her hair had covered
but in that society that they were
living in it was bringing a reproach
upon the church
so coming to the specific verses of 14
to 16 Paul had been using illustrations
from nature and the creation of man and
woman again in that culture men had
short hair compared to the women so he
was emphasizing that a woman's hair for
her was covering for her glory compared
to a man having long hair being shameful
so you can see he was giving a positive
example for a woman to have her hair
covered or her head covered in public
and uh it this verse 16 If any man be
contentious meaning if some were still
defiant about what he had said regarding
a woman having her head covered then
that it was the common custom of the
churches of God he was bringing that out
and then so the takeaway from this this
scripture here I look at three things
whatever we're doing we need to consider
what influence we're giving to others
around us amen and number two be
considerate of the cultural norms and if
possible try not to offend or bring
reproach upon God and I think the third
thing we can make get out of this is we
see he's giving a distinction here
between male and female amen he actually
brings that out the male and the female
so I think you know even though the
society today might be trying to blur
that differentiation between male and
female god brings it out here that there
is a distinction yes thank you again for
that question amen thank you sir thank
you all right Daniel Perry here's your
first
question in Matthew CH 24:1 17 Jesus
told of the destruction of Jerusalem and
instructed them not to even go down to
take anything from their house but it
would be three years before the Roman
armies returned so why were they given
this instruction to be in such a hurry
that's from Jenny in Arizona who texted
that to us all right thank you Jenny for
that question now Matthew 24 Jesus is
this sermon uh in the last week of his
life he's talking about the destruction
of Jerusalem in ad70 with also
applications for the end times as well
and so we'll find things here that
definitely apply to us so let's read
Matthew 24: 15 to1 18 therefore when you
see the abomination of desolation spoken
of by Daniel the Prophet standing in the
Holy Place whoever reads let him
understand now the Christians who
understood this recognize that the Roman
army surrounding the city was a
fulfillment of this then let those who
are in Judea flee to the mountains let
him who is on the housetop not go down
to take anything out of his house in
other words go quickly and let him who
is in the field not go back to get his
clothes now the reason for this now now
there there's you're right there are two
things that happened uh cestius Gus
surrounded the city all right and then
withdrew his troops and then it was 3
years later that Titus in ad70 destroyed
the the city but the reason here is very
similar to why God had Noah enter the
ark 7 days before the storm the flood
came number one it was an Act of Faith
both for Noah and for these Christians
number two it was a testimony of witness
to those around them and an invitation
and number three it shielded them from
violence Noah and his family shielded
from the violence that could have been
going on outside of the Ark and what
happened during those three years was
not a time of Peace it was time of of of
upheaval and uis uprisings and it was a
troubled time and and so those
Christians who escaped were able to to
avoid all that number four it drew them
closer to God I'm talking about Noah
here before that storm came to be close
with God and before this uh destruction
of Jerusalem came these Christians had
the opportunity where they went off into
the mountains they went to
Pella a situation out in the mountainous
area where they were able to draw closer
to God
there was already unrest in Jerusalem
and anybody could see that the
destruction of the city was coming and
so uh when cestius gallus came there and
he was tasked with smothering a revolt
and then he was not a trained military
leader but and so he he would drew his
troops unexpectedly and this opened up a
very brief window for the Christians to
get out of the city because the the the
violent Jews had been already pushed out
of that area and now the Romans had
withdrawn from that area and this
offered them a short window of time when
they could peacefully Escape From the
City it was the time to go and the time
was now and the sign was specific it was
clear and it was decisive and here's
some principles that you and I learn
from this there's a time for Preparation
and there's a Time for Action and when
it's time for Action uh the preparation
should already be completed when the
time came to flee to Jerusalem that was
not the time for deciding what's most
important to take with you all of your
go bag needed to be prepped and ready in
advance and Christians who were watchful
of the times there at that time could
see that it was coming and you and I if
we're watching the times today we can
see the time of preparation is now and a
time of action and decision making is
soon before us so all the preparation
needed to be made in advance we're not
to wait until the last minute to get out
of danger if we if we put things in a
human perspective we might think why
don't I just wait till the very edge the
very last minute if they had waited till
they thought that it was time it would
have been too late and so in that
intervening time those 3 years it was
not a time of Peace it was not a time
where it would have been easy to get out
of there and finally don't be like lot
who carried in the city he waited
because he wanted to hold on to those
things obey by faith what God is asking
you even before it seems like it's time
to go when God says go it's time to go
whether we think so or not don't wait
until the last minute to obey what God
asks you to do look for the clear
instructions and watch for the clear
signs and be ready to take the steps of
faith that God puts before you on time
which is his time amen amen thank you
very much for that answer all right
Shelly here's your second question okay
does going to church make us heavenbound
that's from Angela in Guyana
who chatted that to us okay Angela both
the Old Testament and the New Testament
testify to the importance of a spiritual
Community God's spiritual community and
corporate faithfulness and this is what
helps us maintain spiritual growth when
we attend church we worship in song We
Worship in the word we worship in in
prayer together as a corporate body we
fellowship with one another and it's a
blessed thing and I just have to say
that UPF front if your church service
isn't Dynamic if you say you know this
is boring pray to God when you go to
church don't just go to get a blessing
pray that God will make you a blessing
be a blessing So my answer to your
question Angela no going to church does
not make you heavenbound let me give you
Ephesians 2: 8 and 9 for by Grace you
have been saved through faith that not
of yourselves it is the gift of God not
of Works lest any should boast only
entering into a covenant
relationship with the Lord Jesus Christ
is accepting him as your savior and also
Lord over the matters of your life it is
only by his blood you are saved it is
only by his righteousness you are saved
Romans 8:14 also tells us that to be a
child of God we must be led by the Holy
Spirit John
1518 we see in John 15 Jesus tells the
parable of the vine and he makes it very
clear you have to abide remain in a
relationship with him to be
saved but I have to say this the church
it may not going to church won't save
you without that relationship but don't
dismiss the importance of the church to
God the church is the body of Christ
Ephesians 1:22 says he is the head if
we're in Christ we're members of his
body according to Romans 12:5 it's also
known as the bride of Christ the
household of God the building of God
Hebrews 10:2
2425 says this let us not consider one
another let us consider one another in
order to stir up love this is mutual
encouragement and good works Mutual
efforts to spread the gospel not
forsaking the Assembly of ourselves
together as is the manner of son some
but exhorting one another and so much
more as you see the day
coming worship corporate worship is a
vital resource to Abiding and growing in
our relationship with amen amen thank
you sister thank you all right brother
Marone I got your second question for
you all right I like this one which
commandment can we break and still live
with Christ eternally that's from
Bridget who texted that to us that is a
great question Bridget and you know
you're in good company because there was
a rich young ruler that had a similar
question there about eternal life in
Mark 10 beginning with verse 17 we'll
read that
and when he was gone forth into the way
there came one running and kneeled to
him and asked him good Master what shall
I do that I may inherit eternal life and
Jesus said unto him why callest thou me
good there's none good but one that is
God thou knowest the Commandments do not
commit adultery do not kill do not steal
do not bear false witness defraud not
honor thy father and mother and he
answered and said unto him master all
these have I observed from my
youth then Jesus beholding him loved him
and said unto him one thing thou lackest
go thy way sell whatsoever thou Hast and
give to the poor and thou shalt have
treasure in heaven and come take up the
cross and follow me and he was sad at
that saying and went away grieved for he
had great possessions you know Jesus
knew the one thing that this guy lacked
and that was this selfish nature that he
had and he was thinking about himself
how he could care for himself take care
of himself rather than trusting God to
do that and next verse in 23 Jesus
looked about him and said unto his
disciples how hardly shall they that
have riches enter into the kingdom of
God and the disciples were astonished at
his words but Jesus answered again and
saith unto them children how hard it is
for them that trust in their riches to
enter into the kingdom of God it's
easier for a to go through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of God and they were astonished
out of measure saying among themselves
who then can be saved it was the belief
that if God was blessing you and had a
lot of money then you were good with God
and Jesus looking upon them said with
men it is
impossible but with God not with God for
With God all things are possible amen so
and it says but many that are first
shall be last and the last shall be
first so selfishness is actually death
selflessness is life and selfishness
came into this into mankind when Adam
took that forbidden fruit and only Jesus
lived a totally selfless life so it's
only as we look to him look to Jesus and
see God's sacrificial love for us and
then accept and embrace it will we be
selfless ourselves then we will be able
to live with God in that selfless
Kingdom Revelation 21:7 says he that
overcometh shall inherit all things and
I'll be his God and he shall be my son
so Bridget overcoming our selfishness is
the only way that we can live with Jesus
eternally and it's actually impossible
to do this without God so recognizing
our helplessness trusting totally in him
is the only hope and he's reaching out
to you saying unto you come unto me and
I'll give you rest thank you for the
question amen amen
amen all right brother pin I've got your
second question
why are there so many people in the
Bible with the same name or so similar
that it can be confusing that's from
Michelle in Alabama who texted that to
us all right Michelle thank you for this
question I want you to know and all of
you to know that this is not an
unimportant question there are no
unimportant questions because we tell
you here read your Bible but honestly
sometimes it can be confusing sometimes
we come across things that are new to us
so we wonder why is it like this these
these names why is it so difficult and
the answer is that it's it's really the
issue of familiarity and the issue of
different languages you'd have the same
problem if you were reading stuff from
Chinese literature or stuff from Indian
literature uh it would be the same so
imagine if I were to talk about John or
sha or Don or Ron or Jonathan or Ronald
or
Donovan we're familiar with all those
names and I I know the differences
between them and I'm not confused
especially if I know that those names
apply to people who I know and I know
the difference between Shawn and Ron I
know who they are because I'm familiar
with them and so that's the issue right
here the more we read in the Bible the
more familiar we will be with it and
easier to understand people would always
say to my brother and me we can't tell
the two of you apart I'm like are you
serious we're not alike at all and
people say that about my kids wow
they're all so similar I said spend some
time with them and then you'll recognize
how different they really are and so the
same thing will happen with the Bible
the more you spend the time in it you'll
understand who ahaz and ahaziah and
Azariah and a haueris really really are
because these names these people are
part of the telling of God's story and
you know honestly his name can be
unfamiliar to us until we get to know
him as well and that's the whole story
right there let's get to know God
through the word that he's given to us
amen
amen well before I give shell her her
next question I want to remind you at
home how you can participate you can
participate by one of three ways you can
send in your questions to email by Bible
QA
3m. or you can text your questions in to
618 228 3975 or for those of you who are
on Instagram you can send us your
questions at 3abn official all right
Shelly here's your third question
is Jesus the literal Son of God or a
metaphor that's from Elijah who chatted
that to us Elijah thank you for this
question I've written a 286 page book
called spotless the Everlasting Covenant
and it follows and tracks the
progressive revelation of the messiah's
identity from Genesis to Revelation let
me try but it doesn't get there till
chapter 12 so there's I'm going to try
to pack a lot in a short period of
time the person of Jesus Christ if if we
think of him we have to understand to
understand his identity we have to know
the Covenant
titles the Son of God that is a covenant
title it is not a metaphor Jesus was the
Covenant Son of God the second person of
the god godhead became the son of man of
Mary the son of man took on human flesh
to become the Son of God and the first
person of the godhead then declared
himself to be the person of Jesus Christ
to be his father that's what God did
with all of his human Covenant Sons now
I hope I'm not confusing you Hebrews 1:5
God
says for to which of the Angels did he
ever say you are my son this is the the
godhead in heaven speaking to the
godhead person on Earth to you are my
son today I have begotten you that word
begotten is a covenant term meaning
chosen for Covenant purpose
and
again here's he's quoting the author of
Hebrews is quoting he not only said
today I've begotten you and he said I
will be to him a father and he shall be
to me a son the second person of the
godhead came to Earth to take on our
flesh and he became the son of man that
was Christ's favorite Covenant title he
used that of himself more than any
but the second person of the godhead not
only became the son of man but he became
the Covenant unique Covenant Son of God
let me give you some examples in Luke
135 the angel told Mary that she was
going to give a miraculous birth and he
says to the angel says to Mary that Holy
one who is to be born will be called
the Son of God did you know that Luke
3:38 Adam the first representative of
humanity was called the Son of God did
you know that Exodus
4:22 God called the nation of Israel he
says to Moses go say to Pharaoh thus
says the Lord Israel is my son my
firstborn now firstborn is Covenant
language meaning preeminent
so to be firstborn means that you're the
rightful Heir Israel wasn't the first
nation but God called them the firstborn
Covenant Nation um God said to David in
Psalm
8626 through 29 he shall cry to me he's
saying you will cry to me you are my
father my God and the rock of my
salvation also I will make him my
firstborn speaking of David he was
preeminent in the Covenant position he
was the and he goes on to say the
highest Kings of the earth my Mercy I
will keep with him forever and my
Covenant will stand firm with him
Colossians 1 15 says Jesus is the in
image of the invisible God the firstborn
over all creation and he says all things
were created through him firstborn means
preeminent beg Got U Deuteronomy 32:18 I
want to show you some begotten God told
the nation of Israel he was the father
who had begotten them first Corinthians
4:15 Paul wrote he had begotten the
Corinthians so the only begotten is the
unique one-of-a-kind Covenant Son Of
Promise the heir of the Covenant promise
just like Abraham's son Isaac was the
only begotten got listed in Hebrews 11:1
17-19 Jesus the second person of the
godhead when he came down to become the
person of Jesus Christ he became the
unique only begotten Son of God amen
amen thank you for that thorough answer
amen you probably need some more time to
say some more yeah 12 chapters
worth all right brother Mone here's your
third
question if one person is 15 years older
than the other person would that be
considered as unequally yolked and
that's from Sue who texted that to us
thank you sue great
question let me read that for our
viewers and uh listeners here in uh 2
Corinthians chapter 6 verse
14 and onward do not be unequally yolked
together with unbelievers for what fell
Fellowship has righteousness with un
with lawlessness and what communion has
light with darkness and what Accord has
Christ with bellel or what part has a
Believer with an unbeliever and what
agreement has a temple of God with Idols
for you are the Temple of the Living God
as God has said I will dwell in them and
walk among them and I will be their God
and they shall be my people so there's
the actual context of what you asked
there about being unequally Yol and this
text has been used for a lot of
different things but it's specifically
talking about Believers versus
unbelievers you know in the as far as
being yolked together in the farming
days with animals days um and Amish
still do this but they'll put a Yol
which is a little wooden thing there or
big wooden thing and then the animal
would put his head through and so if you
have two animals one let's say is an ox
and one's a a donkey or a horse they
don't pull the same they in fact they
probably wouldn't get along with each
other so it wouldn't be a good idea so
if you have one horse you know and then
you want two you something's going to be
heavier so we put two horses together in
fact by the way that's how we got
horsepower you know one horsepower two
horsepower three and of course we got
vehicles that have a lot of horsepower
today but it came from that saying there
so um so even though this text is
specific to Believers versus unbelievers
we have used that you know like
nationalities so basically what you're
kind of coming across here can you both
pull together you know if you're a
business partner far as unequally Yol do
have the same ideas or marriage partner
are you going to be coming together uh
with the same pulling power you know
maybe somebody be pulling One Direction
somebody pulling another Direction and
then we say a team of horses right so
are you on the same team so if you're
considering a spouse you know 15 years
difference or you know
just a friend even so thinking about all
of those things so basically that's it
as far as you're deciding far as this
15-year difference you know can you be
pulling together thank you again for
that question amen thank you sir thank
you very much all right brother parent
here's your third
question how do we know step was stoned
in 34 ad that's from Ken in New York who
texted that to us all right Ken thank
you for that question I have asked asked
that question myself before so the 70
the 70 week symbolic time prophecy of
Daniel 9 which is 490 literal years
began to roll in 457 BC when uh the
Persian king Arta Xerxes issued the
command to both restore and rebuild the
city of Jerusalem so 457 BC is the
starting point counting forward those
490 years takes us to the conclusion of
ad. 34 what happened then well a
combination of both historical data and
the Bible record indicate that Steven
was stoned at that time and I'll show
you how in the early 1900s
archaeologists uncovered in the city of
deli near Corinth there at the Temple of
Apollo something called the deli
inscription also called the Gallo
inscription so the Gallo inscription is
a collection of fragments nine fragments
of a letter written by Emperor Claudius
dated precisely pretty precis ly in ad
52 now Gallo's name is clearly seen on
the top line of this and from what is
written there it's clear that he was the
proconsul of AA for a very short period
of time during the the previous year so
that would have been 51 ad acts 18 tells
us that Paul spent 18 months in Corinth
there during the time when Gallo was
there we read about that in Acts 18: 12
to1 17 that tells us that a short time
before Paul took his final trip to
Jerusalem he was accusations were made
against him and he was brought before
Gallo the proconsul of AA in Corinth and
the Gallo dismissed the charges against
Paul so he was free to go and soon after
take his journey to Jerusalem now
Galatians 2 ver1 tells us that 14 that
that this happened 14 years after his
previous visit to Jerusalem and then
Galatians 1:18 tells us that it was this
was 3 years that that was 3 years after
his conversion acts 9 1-16 tells us that
Paul was converted while on his way to
bring Christians back in Chains to
Jerusalem and this is because a great
persecution had just begun well what
started that persecution Acts 8: 1-2
says that the great persecution began
right after Saul oversaw the stoning to
death of Steven so starting with ad51 we
subtract 14 years and 3 years 17 years
and it takes us back to
834 when Paul was converted which
happened right after the stoning of
Steven and so this lets us know we put
those those records together and we can
see clearly what happened step recounted
to the Jewish leaders the history the
the history of the Jews of Israel
rejecting Jesus as the Messiah and their
response was to kill him and salvation
was then spread far and wide to the
Gentiles as well and so both the
historical record and the biblical
record which uh which agree with each
other indicate that step was stoned and
that was the closing of this 490 year 70
week long Prophecy from Daniel chapter
amen you very much if you go to our call
center you can get a little book by
James raffy called Messiah great little
book and the last chapter is called
evidence for 834 if you want to read a
little bit more about that all right
amen so go get that book all right
Shelley here's your fourth and final
question okay can you please explain
what Paul is saying in Colossians
chapter 2 verse1 16 that's from Karen
who emailed that to us oh Karen this
used to plague me it was probably the
year 200000 that I spent three months
studying this and figured it out um
first let me say what did Jesus nail to
the Cross how would you answer that
there's three important things 1 Peter
2:24 for said Christ bore our sins in
his body he paid our sin debt at the
cross so his Precious Blood blotted Out
our certificate of indebtedness to God
Romans 66 says our old man was crucified
with him that the body of sin might be
done away with that we should no longer
be slaves to sin that was the second
thing but what happens in Colossians
214-1 17 we'll look at it Paul is
explaining food and drink offerings
festivals annual sabbaths those were
special Festival uh days of Celebration
they could fall on any day of the week
but these were something that
symbolically shadowed the ministry of
Christ and was nailed to the cross see
these were recorded in the book of the
law the book of the Covenant from Exodus
after God spoke The Ten Commandments
Moses went up he got the book The the
Civil ceremonial and religious laws and
so that goes from about Exodus 2022 over
into Exodus 20 Genesis Exodus no I said
it right Exodus 23 but then in
Deuteronomy God
expanded these laws and here's what it
says Deuteronomy
31:26 Moses gives his final sermon he's
writing down these civil ceremonial and
and and religious laws and he says take
this book of the law Moses handwriting
he's writing it out put it beside the
Ark of the Covenant of the Lord your God
that it may be there as a witness
against you inside the ark was the Ten
Commandments in a pocket on the outside
was the book of the the law because it
was temporary it was there it had the
blessings and the cursings and it was a
witness against them if they sin now
let's read carefully Colossians 213
through1 17 you being dead in your
transgressions and trespasses and
uncircumcision of your flesh he has made
alive together with him having forgiven
you all trespasses having wiped out the
handwriting of requirements that was
against us which was contrary to us he
has taken it out of the way having
nailed it to the Cross having disarmed
principalities and Powers he made a
public spectacle of them triumphing over
them Christ defeated Satan at the cross
so therefore this is what he's saying
he's nailed this to the Cross this thing
that was a witness against us so let no
one judge you in food or in drink that's
the ceremonial food and drink offerings
of the old Covenant or regarding a
festival or a new moon or Sabbath that's
a little lowercase s with an S this is
the annual Sabbath of the
festivals the feast days he said in
verse 17 which are a shadow of things to
come but the substance is Christ Hebrews
8:13 says that the New Covenant made the
old Covenant OB isolate so he is talking
about that old Covenant amen amen thank
you very
much all right brother morone here's
your fourth and final
question if you've been returning ties
and offerings on your earnings and are
now retired do you still return ties
from your pension that's from Linda who
texted that to us thank you Linda I'm
sure other people have that same
question so thank you for sending that
one in
this is
um um I'm going go to Deuteronomy
chapter 14: 22 talking about tithe says
Thou shalt truly tithe all the
increase of thy seed and the field
bringeth forth year by year that the
field bringeth forth so the Bible says
to tithe our increase or our profit so
like if let's say you uh going to plant
some corn you buy $10 worth of corn seed
and you plant it and then you sell your
corn at the end the Harvest and then you
make $100 you sell it for $100 so your
profit would be that what you invested
the beginning uh the $10 so you would
have $90 that would be your increase or
your profit so your tithe on that would
be $9 or 10% tithe this means 10% so the
Israelites oh actually they did um maybe
25 to 30% of their profit they would
give back to the Lord all the different
offerings that he had so if you study
that out it's amazing uh what they did
and how God blessed them with all of
their
generosity so technically if you've been
tithing your gross earnings and are now
living on what you already tithed then
you wouldn't need to you know as a
pastor though I always encourage people
to listen to the Holy Spirit as the Holy
Spirit would speak to them in
Malachi 3: 10 it's let me just read it
here it says um bring ye all the tithes
into the storehouse that there may be
food in my house and try me now or prove
me now in the King James it says the
Lord says of host if I will not open you
the windows of heaven and pour out for
you such a blessing that there will be
no room for you to receive it all isn't
that a neat promise you know and Valerie
and I my wife and I we've it's just
that's so neat to watch how the Lord
blesses you so many times so many
stories how would take care of us he's
just such a good God Amen and um
so people you know they ask that far as
giving from their net or their gross you
know far as your gross pay would
be um what you get you know what your
check is written out for but then you'll
see all these things that were taken out
of your check right and uh you said man
where did all that go but if you think
about that as far as the gross you know
you're getting benefit from all of these
other things you know our taxes you know
they cover all kind kind of stuff that
we're benefiting from the roads that we
drive on you know um anyway thinking out
it from all different angles the police
department Fire Department 911 services
all kinds of things so you know people
call into the Pastoral department and
they ask comeing similar questions I
remember this one lady one time called
and she was being taken care of by uh I
don't remember if she was in a nursing
home some kind of facility where now all
of her money the money that she had
through the years she was faithful tithe
pairer donated 3abn and now she wasn't
able to do that because her check was
taken away from her so she was feeling
really bad like she might be robbing God
type of a thing so I shared with her you
know it's kind of like all this money is
taken out while you're living we're kind
of contributing to a pot we could say
and then when it's our turn that now we
are being taken care of ourselves you we
contributed into that pot but now this
pot is taking care of us and not to feel
bad you could tell by her voice that she
felt a lot better about that that she
wasn't you know she wasn't making an
increase and uh anyway that was a neat
thing that the Lord allowed me to share
with this woman and she felt so good
about that and peaceful that God was
taking care of her really it's God
taking care of us through the system
that's set up here thank you again for
that question amen amen thank you
brother
morone all right brother parin here's
your fourth and final question
does Jesus really mean what he says in
Mark 10: 21 when he says to sell
everything we have and give to the poor
or is this symbolic language that's from
Maurice who emailed that to us all right
Maurice thank you for your question and
it starts out with does Jesus really
mean what he says I'm gonna I'm going to
start with yes he does but I got to tell
you we don't we don't plan things this
way here's my brother Daniel sitting
next to me my name's Daniel he dealt
with the Rich Young Ruler I'm dealing
with the Rich Young Ruler he dealt with
money I'm dealing with a question about
money and so someone out there these
questions are designed straight for you
so here's this young man who comes to
Jesus he says one came running that's in
Mark 10:17 knelt before him and says
good teacher what shall I do he says why
do you call me good and and he says I I
keep the Commandments and then Jesus
says to him verse 21 looking at him he
loved him I love that Jesus loved him am
CU he loves you he said to him one thing
you lack go your way s whatever you have
and give to the poor and you will have
treasure in heaven and come take up the
cross and follow me but the man was sad
he went away because he had lots of
stuff and he didn't want to leave it now
this is not symbolic language Jesus
actually meant it h he and and the
person he was talking to knew that Jesus
meant it and that's why he walked away
so sadly because he had a lot of things
he did not want to give up and even
though Jesus instruction to this person
was literal Jesus only gave this
specific instruction to one person he
didn't say the same thing to zachus he
didn't say the same thing to Nicodemus
he didn't say the same thing to the
Samaritan woman now he did tell John and
James the brothers to leave their Nets
and follow him but from this brief
description of this man we recognize
that Jesus saw into his heart and he
recognized that his possessions had
become his God and there's no way that
he could follow God without letting that
God that false god go you see God's
instructions are sometimes uh true for
everybody in all situations like the Ten
Commandments of moral Behavior but some
instructions that Jesus gives are
specific and they illustrate principles
that apply to all people so when Jesus
tells James and John to leave their Nets
and follow him he gave them a specific
instruction that Illustrated a full life
of commitment to him but that's that
doesn't mean he's telling all of us to
leave our careers to leave our jobs
behind that's not a specific instruction
he's given to
everybody for this young man Jesus saw
that the specific instruction would
reveal his selfishness and that selfish
this is all out of Jesus love for him
because Jesus wants this man to be freed
from the selfish heart and have his
heart fully committed to God so he can
receive all the blessings that come from
God see the blessings didn't come from
The Obedience blessings come come when
we are obedient but it doesn't come from
obedience it comes from having a heart
committed fully to God this specific
instruction is an illustration of Bible
principles that apply to everybody but
there are and here are some of those
principles hold your possessions Loosely
they don't they don't belong to you you
can see that in Matthew 6:1 19 to 21
care for the needs of the poor this is a
Bible principle and we find this in
places like Isaiah 58 and we see that
principle that Jesus shares with this
young man to not love your money in
place of God this is a Bible principle
that we find in places like 1 Timothy 6
that says not to be greedy the the love
of money is the root of all evil but you
have to remember that there are other
biblical principles that we need to
apply for example 1 Corinthians 16
verses 1 to 4 Paul writes to uh the the
the Christians in Corinth and instructs
them to set apart some money for giving
each week not all their money some money
in 1 Timothy 58 we are told to take care
of the needs of our families I've got
children as you know and God has not
asked me to take everything I own and
sell it and leave my children destitute
and homeless and hungry that that
wouldn't be in agreement with the
principles God has given amen so let me
leave you with James 1 5 and 6 and this
is also in agreement with what Pastor
morone just said if any of you lacks
wisdom let him ask of God who gives to
all liberally and without reproach and
it will be given to him but let him ask
in faith with no doubting for He Who
doubts is like a wave of the sea driven
and tossed by the
wind all the money that you have all the
possessions that you have they're God's
it's his money it's his stuff that he's
given to you he knows what to do with it
if you really want to know to what
degree this command is literal for you
all right the principle is to be fully
devoted to God in all your ways and all
your things but to what degree this is
literal what amount that God would have
you to give ask of him ask God honestly
with a willing heart study the
principles that are revealed in
scripture with prayer and God will be
your teacher amen amen amen am amen you
know could I add something before we go
to break I'm prid somebody who won't be
there is we were talking and and
answering Angela's question about is
going to church making you
heavenbound while the church and my
answer was no it's only your
relationship with the Lord but we
emphasized the importance of church and
we see it in Acts
2:42 that the early church got together
and they fellowshipped and went from
house to house and they were devoted to
their faith and unity with the others
but here here's what I want to add some
people may be elderly frail or you may
have an immune system
problem uh I have some issues myself
please understand you do not feel
condemned if you cannot go to church as
important as church is to God please
understand that you can still have a
robust
life of Faith you can watch 3ab and many
letters come in saying they do that
we're their church but you can pray and
intercede for others so don't ever feel
guilty about that amen amen thanks for
saying
that well I hope you've been blessed by
all the answers that we found here in
God's word we're going to take a short
break here in just a moment so that you
can uh know how you can participate with
3abn today Bible Q&A so I want to make
sure that you don't go away cuz we're
going to be right here with some final
thoughts so come back and join us
again if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
3abn.org
[Music]
some final thoughts from our panelists
sister Shelly final thought would be if
you want to understand the Covenant
relationship please we have a series
it's called spotless the Everlasting
Covenant we also have a a book that's
free it's a beautiful book 286 Pages
called spotless experiencing the
Everlasting Covenant through
righteousness by Faith Tune in and get a
book as well amen Amen brother morone
final thoughts well I mentioned that
Valerie and I have seen how the Lord has
taken care of us through the years and
just really blessed us so you know as
far as um doing your tithe and offerings
you can't outgive the Lord we found that
out so as the Lord impresses you to give
and whether it's your from your
retirement you know the Lord will lead
you and guide you whether you should or
shouldn't or whether you can't afford it
or not but he says proove us or test us
and you could try it out and see what
the Lord does he'll he'll bless you I'm
sure
amen amen you know this is true at all
times but more and more and more so as
we draw closer to Jesus coming we need
the holy spirit amen not just as an idea
or a concept but to be earnestly
pleading and asking and God promises
that he will respond to that he says if
you then being evil know how to give
good gifts to your children how much
more will your heavenly father give the
Holy Spirit to those who ask him and so
if we ask for the Holy Spirit we will
receive and that gives us wisdom and
what we should do with all of our
possessions
finally before I hand it off to Ricky
here get to know those funny names in
the Bible because you're going to meet
some of them in heaven you don't want to
look at them and say who are you now
meet that guy in the Bible and then meet
him in heaven or that lady amen amen
well thanks for joining us want to leave
you with this fun scripture song Thy
word have I hid in my heart that I might
not sin against you Psalms 119 ver
11 thanks and God bless
[Music]